right
I love podcast Lords of gaming.net and
we are in the realm of packing which is
fine gentlemen in the realm of HBO yes
hi my name is Peter Mai I Am The Omen
gaming displays product planner so uh
we're here on building our brand new
omega display plan
I'm excited for everyone to see it
awesome we love gaming monitors we love
that type of uh product so let's take a
look at the live what's going on over
here awesome yeah so
okay
this setting
capacity
[Music]
it's about HDMI 2.1 on here for that
awesome spot
we're happy yeah 4K 120 yeah and serve
you don't mind I'll actually show a
pretty cool feature here so we have KVM
build
skull so you just
press that button on the back and you
can flip right over
to your home and
then
yeah
so this will be the again emphasis time
it's like part of our zero punch on top
of the line here
I mean this is my favorite but yeah yeah
all right so let's move on what else we
got yeah so we got our home at 34
yeah right next to our home
work
and the cool thing about that is all of
our stands on all these new monitors are
broken fully ergonomic
uh till we do those sorts of things
right there nice but more importantly we
got our 34C this is our biggest monitor
in the line
immersive landscape you can see him play
Minecraft
[Music]
as well what else we got next yeah
it's actually just our 4K again just
showcase some kind of depends on though
yeah but off to the side here we go one
of our 27
[Music]
years yeah
I need my Frank yeah
yeah
great speakers
are hyper experts
we got some pretty cool things
yeah
because we got next yeah
240 hertz monitors we're actually
running
right now and
the water set up here so
I should mention both of our 240Hz
monitors if you do have to
use
I would love this on the PC Master race
guy and I love my frames I love about
Clarity oh these are beautiful I
put me down all right sounds good also
I'll add up everything here too we have
Visa adapters
looks great the third party are also
safe
unfortunately
all right
try to get old okay
evolving any last thing you want to say
could be complete to get that Pinterest
product what else would they live back
to
them they may not know already yeah so
what I want to say is this is really
kind of our first major jump into an
expansive lineup underneath that Omen
brand and what we're doing here is
really bringing that premium experience
that you're known for through Omen down
into what we consider the mainstream for
gaming monitors nice so as you can see
we're expanding we're going from Full HD
to 4K 24 to 34 inches really there's
something here for every style of gamer
and the important thing is it's all very
well priced so you get a lot of value
for your dollar yeah it's great to see
man love what HP is doing in the gaming
space an absolute pleasure always you
see them ahead of the curve to give you
that flexibility that adaptability in
the gaming space HP Omen packs East